we got this from the week
defendants in alleged whitmer kidnapping
plot are arguing fbi informants
engineered plan now i'll just say this i
mean that's that's that's a heavy piece
of what we're going to talk about
it's one thing to make that accusation
it's another thing when buzzfeed news of
all outlets comes out and says there are
questions as to whether or not there
would have even been a conspiracy were
it not for the fbi and then there's
questions of law do you think that
federal prosecutors are going to drop
this case simply because it's now being
exposed by the media maybe not but it's
possible i just really doubt it there's
not gonna be political willpower and
especially when democrats want to use
this to their advantage but let me show
you this so this is the story from the
week right and they're basically
pointing out the
the section of the buzzfeed article
about the defendant saying they're
accusing the fbi of effectively
orchestrating this buzzfeed
buzzfeed news says
an examination of the case by buzzfeed
news also reveals some of those
informants of which they were 12
acting under the direction of the fbi
played a far larger role than has
previously been reported working in
secret they did more than just passively
observe and report on the actions of the
suspects instead they had a hand in
nearly every aspect of the alleged plot
starting with its inception the extent
of their involvement raises questions as
to whether there would have even been a
conspiracy without them i'll do you one
better buzzfeed i can appreciate that
they put that in there that is an
opinion however
but i can give my opinion when you when
you go on to mention that a longtime
government of informant helped organize
a series of meetings around the country
where many of the legit plotters first
met one one another
yeah there wouldn't be without the fbi
they they set the meetings so okay look
the fbi is going to argue hey hey hey we
gave them the space and we we made those
statements but they made those choices i
don't know what do you guys what do you
guys what do you guys think it's
disgusting i think it's only it's it's
incitement unless the fbi is doing it
apparently it's only illegal unless the
president does it like come on
trump didn't say anything anywhere near
as as crazy as these people were saying
if if if the fbi goes to somebody that's
mentally unstable and puts a gun in
their hand and says
encourages them or points them in the
direction of someone that they want like
that's
how can you blame that that
i guess you got to blame the gunman but
but obviously you blame charles manson
when the other guy went out and stabbed
the people they were giving these guys
military training
what what do you think about it pedro
this is what the fbi does i mean this is
what the feds do they
create these plots they provide the
training
the logistical coordination
and then they basically entrap their
victims and so the question is why do
they do that right
i think there are different answers to
that i think one it's politically useful
because trump is bad trump was a fascist
of course i'm just being sarcastic but i
think so it's politically useful from
that angle at least for the democratic
party but on the other hand i mean this
is this is good business for the fbi
right this is job security if you have
these kinds of threats if you have these
kinds of coordinated very dangerous
highly motivated actors then you you
need the fbi
you don't just need the fbi you the fbi
needs a bigger budget it needs to expand
its operations into different aspects of
not just
public life but also private life it
needs to know more about what americans
are doing so that it can make sure that
these things don't happen and the fact
that the fbi is you know the driving
cause of these things happening well
that's just a little footnote that we
don't need to really get into
i don't think there's
a solution to
i don't think there's an easy solution
to corruption that's an easy solution
you know i'm thinking about like okay
what if we didn't have government fbi
right what if we had private
investigatory agencies and you hired
them instead of having to go and make a
petition and cross your fingers hope
they actually look into the case maybe
you go and hire a company well then any
company could be incentivized to do
criminal activities for for the sake of
making money right so let's say you're a
window repair company and you know
you're you're a private company you make
money when windows get broken
certainly excited when you hear antifa's
rioting so any any any individual who is
sufficiently corrupt or who has
monopolistic power could be susceptible
to saying okay how can we encourage more
riots and support some more of this
activism and encourage this stuff
because inadvertently it allows us to
sell more windows actually ryan long had
that comedy segment have you seen that
one where it's like antifa window repair
and he's like we're both simultaneously
antifa and the window repair company but
anyway i digress when you have the fbi
and they have a monopoly on this and
they want to make money and increase
their budgets there's one way to do it
you need a large and powerful big bang
well here you go
they had they had a dozen informants
so it
it's it's an interesting point first
what is entrapment
this this probably is not enormous
entrapment would be when you coerce
someone by force or or threats
so if a cop went to you and said
if you don't do this i'll hit you that's
entrapment if they said hey wouldn't it
be really awesome if you did this you
should totally do it that's not
entrapment you still chose to do it the
problem is
there's a fine line right i mean you you
actually have the fbi now creating the
means the the the the providing the
resources these things can't happen
without them right like they're who's
going to give military training to a
bunch of random meme you know ish
posters on the internet
that's right no it gets into this
question like you said these blurred
lines
right where it's kind of like choice
architecture
you're laying out all of the instruments
and arguments and logistics for doing
this and you're also
exploiting people who are desperate and
angry and maybe mentally unstable
and your defense is well i just put the
gun on the table
i don't have any responsibility for what
that person did afterwards after i told
them to use the gun and how to use it
and who they should use it on that's not
my fault ian made a good point man it's
incitement it is it seems like
incitement i mean they're they're
encouraging them or getting them revved
up or connecting them to commit a crime
it seemed like let me let me pull this
part of the buzzfeed article they say
this
they say dan steered let me back a
little bit let me move back so i can get
to that point in the context
they say as agents impola and chambers
listen dan pressed him about the meeting
in ohio dublin fox said was about
changing the paradigm the media treated
patriots unfairly after he and hundreds
of other patriots occupied the state
house in lansing they effing called us
domestic terrorists that's a quote quote
we want to take that stigma off and let
them know who we are because we are not
effing racists we are not white
nationalists said fox we just want our
effing constitution upheld and we want
all these lawless effing tyrants out of
effing power it's that simple dan
steered the conversation away from
rhetoric to specific plans
asking fox what the mission was like
what are we looking to go forward with
laughing fox said his dream was to have
quote have the governor hog tied down on
a table for public display the way the
ea dea agent spread gun seized and drug
spread seized guns and drugs across a
table like trophies after a big bust
quote we take the building and then take
effing hostages fox told dan it's effing
warton but by his own admission fox
despite his new seemingly grand military
title was a general without soldiers i
can't do nothing with less than 200 men
he complained to dan at best he figured
he could muster maybe 15 to 20 men
stopping violent ideas like this was
what dan said drove him to law
enforcement in the first place but now
with his two fbi agents at his side he
told fox he would help
they're effectively inciting
and encouraging their creating
circumstances it's incitement donald
trump can say we're going to go
peacefully march and listen to some
politicians or whatever that's what he
said right he had something like you
know have politicians make arguments
and then as trump was speaking the
people at the capitol started pushing
the barricades down fighting with cops
storming their way up to the capitol and
fighting on at the front door
donald trump
did not do anything near what this is
but they say there was a tweet now i
can't i think it was the daily beast i'm
not sure they were like trump's failed
attempt to overthrow the government or
like someone some news outlet tweeted
that like they're just
even the media they're just continually
escalating what really happened on the
six like donald trump gave a speech
where he in no way said go do this stuff
he was like peacefully march and now
they've just slowly turned it into
something totally different like the
lincoln project made this video
where it's a mishmash of what trump was
saying to make it seem like he was
calling for violence
yeah i tell you man it's dark days ahead
huh well there's something related to
this so
we can say that the capitol police
failed right on january 6 they failed to
do their job some conservatives argue
that they facilitated what happened
through their failure however you want
to slice it okay well well tucker says
the fbi
had had informants there probably
orchestrated as well yes that's right
so but we'll grant that so these people
either out of
negligence or malice
they're part of the reason why january 6
happened okay
so what happens after january 6. well
the capital police
has a 2 billion budget with which they
plan to expand operations outside of the
capital first in florida and
florida and california to the most
populous states with plans to open field
offices across the country they've also
borrowed eight they're called persistent
surveillance systems from the us
government the army is going to train
capital police to use these we first
deployed this technology in iraq and
afghanistan to monitor asymmetric
threats in other words we use this
technology against insurgents so now
capital police which is supposed to be
in the capital is expanding operations
across the united states ostensibly to
protect members of congress and they're
also going to be deploying technology
that we used against insurgents on
americans in order to
what this stuff does is
you can create i think it's called
pattern of life it allows you to monitor
people
on a very intimate level to figure out
you know where they eat where they sleep
where they go what their routines are
and things like that but over large
geographical swaths this this is uh this
is not like a like a little camera right
this is huge
surveillance on a mass level
this is fine apparently no one really
seems to have a problem with it and
people are buying the argument that no
the capital police needs to do this they
need to expand operations to these huge
states or actually to to all as many
states as they want and they also need
to deploy
military good equipment that we use on
insurgents against americans
mike cernovich has been tweeting about
this saying that you know he often hears
someone start trying to ramp up the
rhetoric and push it towards some kind
of direct physical action and he always
shuts him down he blocks him or he kicks
him out because he's like we we don't
want any of that we know where that's
going and he's right i keep telling
people you know
peaceful persuasive resourceful that's
how you win a culture war that's how you
you maintain your country and one of the
problems there's there's two big
problems and one conservatives people on
the right the anti-establishment the
anti-woke defected liberal liberals well
i should i'm going to exclude the
defected liberals mostly the right as
we've traditionally known it very weak
on culture
very weak i mean you know people people
mock these like the religious
conservative movie productions and
things like that the daily wires doing a
pretty good job getting into this the
one big advantage i think conservatives
have right now are disaffected liberals
many of whom were in music production
and movie production and show production
culture building wins you the youth and
ten years from now there's going to be
another generation entering politics and
what 10 year olds are being inundated
with today is going to severely impact
what politics will look like in 10 years
so one thing that we saw
i bring up every so often is that you
know we've had some leftists some
younger leftists on the show and they
have no idea what occupy wall street was
they were they were young teenagers when
that was happening and just had no
understanding of what was going on so
now when i base my disdain for joe biden
off of a lot of the obama era they're
like i don't know anything about that
right now you look at what's happening
with with children and the the
indoctrination at schools these kids who
are in these schools getting
indoctrinated 10 years from now are
going to vote as far left as humanly
possible if conservatives and people on
the right don't fight back with
persuasive resourcefulness with
resourcefulness with persuasion being
peaceful and building culture you lose
especially when you see what's going on
with the fbi they're looking for any
opportunity to take that frustration
turn it into some kind of
some expressed desire for action and
then lock you up and then it gives them
even more justification for
indoctrinating kids it's just one after
another one two three punch yeah i think
maybe one example of of a positive
development in the culture is that movie
about richard jewell
the security guard who was basically
screwed by the fbi uh after he he
managed to save a ton of people i think
it was at a baseball game it was some
kind of a sporting event where there was
a bomb
and uh basically the feds
put it on him right that he that the re
they argue that the reason he was able
to find the bomb and save all these
people was because he had in fact
planted it
and the movie was interesting because
richard jewell is like your average
middle american he's this guy who
doesn't have like a college degree uh
he's just patriotic
patriotic
kind of naive about his country and i
mean that in a good way
and here he is being absolutely
railroaded by these horrible corrupt
feds right and i think that that movie
was really interesting precisely because
that
do you have this patriotic person who's
being persecuted by his own foot by the
own by his own government you do not
talk to police that's it it's simple
there's a famous supreme court justice
camera's name long time ago said do not
talk to cops and it's funny there are a
lot of conservatives that seem to think
they're very very they're very naive
about what this country is and it's it's
funny when you see the the uh you know
very
the very heavy back of the blue like
attitudes kind of waning a little bit
with the coveted lockdowns and stuff
um people are you know many people on
the right are starting to realize like
uh i think
you know what man we shout out michael
males too much michael you shout out too
much but he he often says that there is
no law
so uh you know absurd or disgusting or
amoral that a cop would not enforce it
now that may be a bit extreme because i
certainly think there's many things a
cop wouldn't do to be honest however the
proud boys versus antifa is a really
good example of this that they got into
a fight because antifa had been
harassing and patrons one guy got gets
robbed and then finally the proud boys
are like all right you want to fight
a lot of people see the proud boys run
towards antifa but antifa had been
basically like at every corner following
them and as much as they keep trying to
walk away they see antifa at every
corner eventually the proud boys decide
they're going to engage well first of
all that's a mistake don't start fights
you could you can try and go around them
you can try and walk past them they run
at them a fight breaks out okay well if
antifa shows up they're known to be
violent a fight breaks out we can argue
that sometimes fights happen i still
think it's wrong but what happened after
that antifa flees the proud boys decide
to give a statement to the cops because
we trust the cops the cops the good guys
and now guess who went to prison proud
boys antifa none of them yeah thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you